[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
estamos en santiago de cali la tercera
ciudad de colombia donde nos vamos a
encontrar con el alcalde jorge iván
ospina que ha tenido que gestionar las
semanas más difíciles de la ciudad en
décadas el paro nacional de colombia e
inició el 28 de abril y desde entonces
se han producido varias decenas de
muertos pérdidas millonarias y también
la participación de organizaciones
internacionales para desescalar el
conflicto jorge iván muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros la primera pregunta
que le quería dar hacer es qué pasa en
cali qué pasa en colombia
bueno hay carencias de toda la vida pero
lo que tenemos en este momento es
una movilización ciudadana
expresada de manera violenta a partir de
una reforma tributaria en un contexto
muy difícil el que vive nuestra ciudad
yo no sé si tú sabías pero a tan sólo
una hora de cali están los cultivos más
grandes de hoja de coca del mundo 80 mil
hectáreas y los consecuentes
cristalizaderos de donde sale cocaína
estamos muy cerca de las mayores
yacimientos y explotación de minería
ilegal en nuestra ciudad ese oro se
evoluciona y estamos muy cerca de
aquellos grupos
en una paz incompleta operan eso unido a
las carencias de siempre a las carencias
educativas culturales a la demografía
elevada en un periodo muy corto de
tiempo y a la dificultad que se ha
tenido para interpretar estas
situaciones y poderlo resolver la
reforma tributaria
solamente el argumento pero lo que está
de fondo una multiplicidad de
insatisfacciones y violencias usted como
alcalde una de las críticas que se le ha
hecho es que perdió el control en
detrimento del ministerio de defensa que
qué pasó con el liderazgo que ha pasado
en estas dos semanas desde la alcaldía
no cabe duda que perdimos gobernabilidad
y no cabe duda que perdimos
gobernabilidad porque la expresión civil
del estado es superada por la
circunstancia violenta es un tema muy
interesante
los alcaldes no somos fiscalía no somos
policía no somos inteligencia del estado
los alcaldes somos una figura de orden
administrativo que gestiona lo público
localmente
no tiene bajo su administración esas
responsabilidades cuando la situación
violenta se manifiesta perdemos
gobernabilidad y ser responsable esa
fractura nuestra capacidad de gestión si
usted lo desea
efectivamente es nuestra ciudad y
nuestra comunidad y nosotros mismos
hemos perdido autoridad en el desarrollo
de gestionar la crisis estamos ahora en
un proceso de negociaciones en el que
hay múltiples actores no hasta la
alcaldía gobernación el propio gobierno
pero de otro lado está también estuvo la
mina indígena también los jóvenes que
están manifestándose que hablábamos
antes de la entrevista que están también
divididos tenemos también un comité de
paro como están si en nuestras
negociaciones que nos puede contar no
todo es muy complejo es una mezcla en un
escenario difícil pero por ejemplo yo
diría cuando la minga indígena nos dijo
que llegaba nos cerramos las puertas
hablamos con ellos le manifestamos que
estábamos en un momento muy difícil que
como pueblos hermanos deberían
comprender la situación en la que
habitaba acá
definimos un protocolo y un
procedimiento de su llegada
desafortunadamente el mío el mismo no
activo adecuadamente y la minga es
agredida por civiles armados situación
que hay que condenar totalmente y que
hay que judicial izar en relación a los
otros actores y si hay temas locales
pero la trascendencia del asunto es un
asunto nacional los corredores que
abastecen a cali no están en nuestro
territorio y están bloqueados y las
dificultades que uno observa son
dificultades que tras atrás atrás
superan nuestras fronteras y superan en
nuestra capacidad resolutiva es un tema
político un tema social que demanda una
respuesta política una intervención
social una de las mayores críticas de la
comunidad internacional es la violencia
policial estos días nosotros hemos
estado en siloé hemos estado con doña
ángela que es la madre de kevin agudelo
uno de los primeros muertos allá en
siloé
y nos queda la pregunta de qué respuesta
tiene alcaldía de esa actuación policial
y si también a familias destrozadas como
hemos visto con doña ángela si la
institución le va a pedir perdón en
algún momento
hay una cosa que a mí me llama mucho la
atención y es que quienes nos mantenemos
en la institucionalidad local condenamos
enérgicamente los eventos violentos y
los orientamos a la fiscalía general de
la nación para que lo resuelva por tanto
no puede haber allí una especie de
generalización con respecto a quién
cometió ese homicidio no solamente el
homicidio del joven del que tú me hablas
también el homicidio de nicolás mi primo
por tanto es nuestra responsabilidad
llevar esto a los niveles judiciales sin
generalizar la condena porque
generalizando la condena deterioró más
las instituciones maltrechos y al
deteriorar más las instituciones
maltrechas más difícil nos va a ser
resolver los asuntos de seguridad
ciudadana en cal y en relación a pedir
perdón yo no debería pedir perdón por lo
que no he hecho
jamás ha salido de mi escritorio de mi
voz o de mi de mi expresión corporal una
idea de que masacren a las personas por
el contrario no hay un escenario donde
yo plantee que la protesta no se
judicial iza la protesta no se
criminaliza y la protesta no se activa
de forma violenta de tal forma de que me
quedaría muy difícil asumir
responsabilidades no no tenías la
responsabilidad tal vez que podamos
tener nosotros es que
ante la velocidad de los hechos me fue
imposible estar con la bandera blanca en
todos los sitios pero donde pudo estar
con la bandera blanca intentando reducir
la escalada lo hice y ante la velocidad
de los hechos
en muy pocos días nosotros llamamos la
comunidad internacional nosotros
llamamos a los embajadores llamamos a
las organizaciones de derechos humanos y
llamamos la iglesia si el conflicto se
ha escalado en cali es por un papel
protagónico que ha adelantado la
alcaldía
se han visto imágenes de
desabastecimiento se han visto destrozos
se han visto pérdidas millonarias cuando
va a poder recuperar la normalidad tal
ya es poco a poco progresiva es un tema
que no va a ser sencillo lograrlo de
inmediato pero poco a poco lo hemos
logrado de todas formas nuestra sociedad
es una sociedad que se adapta y que es
capaz de salir de crisis de este orden
hoy ya tenemos un poquito más de
transporte masivo 100% de servicios
públicos estamos poco a poco habilitando
todos los que son los corredores de
movilidad en la ciudad pero nos falta
algo muy importante efectivamente tener
una mesa sistemática de conversación con
los actores para que podamos dibujar más
bien sus necesidades y podamos construir
mejor la respuesta su padre fue
militante del m-19 usted estudió
medicina en la habana empezó trabajando
en los barrios más humildes si usted
tuviese 20 años y como nos dicen los
manifestantes sólo una comida al día no
pudiese pagarse los estudios si no
encontrase trabajo usted cree que
también participaría en esa primera
línea
yo creo que sí que es que es lógico y
sabes que cuando la gente me ve me
señala traidor por nuestra historia y me
enseñará traidor porque la gente le
gustaría verme en barrica pero la
barricada tiene tal multiplicidad de
actores tal multiplicidad de presencias
que la barricada no es tan serena como
la barricada que uno podría encontrar la
barricada son una expresión de una
sociedad muy muy difícil como lo de la
nuestra y en mi papel de alcalde mi
responsabilidad tiene que ser más la
responsabilidad de por vías
institucionales resolver lo que la
barricada como problema tiene allí hay
una manifestación muy grande de
dificultades que debemos de resolver
pero también tengo que explicarte que lo
que yo he visto y lo que ha sucedido es
de unas complejidades transnacionales
incluso de unas complejidades que tienen
alimentos y elementos que antes no
existían en un conflicto
esté existiendo una contradicción
violenta entre los manifestantes y la
policía y que 300.000 personas estén
pegadas en directo en las redes viendo
esa película película en vivo o película
real alimenta y consolida la propia
contradicción violenta o ver que a
nicolás después de que lo quieren con
arma de fuego lo llevan lo recogen lo
llevan a la institución de salud narran
su muerte 180 mil personas conectadas en
directo me refiere otra construcción de
orden más semántico comunicativo muy
difícil de resolver o cuando veo
matrices construidas orientadas
establecidas desde muchas partes con la
intención de instalar ciertas ideas no
verdaderas me hace a mí pensar que el
conflicto tiene mucho más de
transnacional de tal forma de que aquí
también quisiera que la gente entendiera
que hay un teatro
teatro una escena una escenografía una
construcción de nuevos modelos de
conflicto modelos de conflicto que no
quisiera calificar pero modelos de
conflicto que evolucionan a partir de
códigos que no estaban establecidos para
explicarte porque el tema de estar en la
barricada no es un tema tan sencillo no
se trata de una protesta únicamente ya
para terminar como conclusión una
pregunta más personal cómo está usted
como lo está viviendo no uno lo vive muy
duro en realidad es una tensión
permanente por ejemplo ayer me me
increpó una estudiante asesino asesino
asesino traidor y yo me miro en el
espejo y pienso jamás de mi boca ha
salido la idea de que maten a los
manifestantes jamás de mi boca ha salido
la idea de la acera la dignidad y la
vida he convocado a la comunidad
internacional y es convocado a que todos
les estimule mos la circunstancia
violenta e identifiquemos a los halcones
de la muerte
es doloroso que me señale así pero no sé
importa la manera como yo lo recibo que
es importante la manera como ella lo
construye ese para mí es un momento muy
angustiante también es muy angustiante
que vaya a la mesa que establezcamos una
mesa con el corazón abierto para
resolver el problema de los jóvenes y
se construye a la idea de que otros
jóvenes en otro sitio están siendo
atacados y efectivamente eso no ocurrió
es una falacia es una construcción
política para deteriorar la mesa y eso
me muestra a mí que las personas que
adelante en las conversaciones deben ser
también mucho más responsables con
nuestro pueblo
muchas gracias alcalde por acompañarnos
y muchas gracias a nuestra audiencia
pueden seguir más contenidos como este
en france 24 y france24 puntocom
y